[Aplausos]
[Música]
y yo para gerardo nació en viena austria
unos meses después de la finalización de
la segunda guerra mundial pero no es
austríaco porque sus padres no nacieron
así entonces el gobierno europeo no le
concedió la nacionalidad
su mamá era serbia y su papá un alemán
al listado con los nazis fue él quien
les recomendó an que viajar a viena para
ir allí y lo esperara pero quien no
hubiera sido mi abuelo nazi jamás
apareció mi abuela con un niño en plena
posguerra decidió emigrar cruzar el
océano y llegó aquí en la argentina en
1950 el día exacto de mi cumpleaños el 4
de julio
aquí volvió a formar pareja con
francisco nadie uno húngaro de los
muchísimos que se asentaron aquí en zona
norte del gran buenos aires francisco a
nagy adoptó mi papá como hijo natural de
ahí mi apellido
mamá liliana es argentina
su familia el alemán del volga un
colectivo que se instaló en el siglo 18
en el río homónimo por impulso de
catalina la grande
pero que unos años después en el marco
de la rusia zarista perdieron ciertas
condiciones y decidieron emigrar
llegaron a nuestro país en la década de
1870 y 1880 depende de cada familia
la familia paterna de mi mamá se radicó
en entre ríos mientras que la familia
materna era italiana y se radicó en los
años 20 en la provincia de buenos aires-
huyendo del fascismo de benito mussolini
el apellido y mamá es herber bertolucci
el italiano silos maría
mi origen paterno es serbio alemán y
húngaro y materno alemán del volga e
italiano
seguramente ustedes pueden contar
historias similares tal vez distintas
pero en las cuales las migraciones son
una constante o un punto de inflexión en
las trayectorias incluso esto no es un
fenómeno exclusivo de nuestro país
hay una frase de octavio paz o que se le
atribuye octavio paz respecto a lo que
somos los mexicanos descienden de los
aztecas los peruanos descienden de los
incas y los argentinos descendemos de
los barcos
somos solamente eso un pueblo descendido
de embarcaciones europeas bueno en
principio tengo que decirles que la
identidad es una construcción social un
imaginario antes que una realidad fácil
ya siente
la mayoría de las identidades
se construyeron en el marco de la
organización de los estados nacionales
en el siglo 19 cuando cada país mordió
su identidad de acuerdo a un territorio
concreto representado en un mapa algo
así esto que estamos acá somos nosotros
tenemos una historia una cultura y a
veces un idioma en común y esos que
están allá son otros
máximo de asedio un constructor de la
del estado italiano tiene una famosa
frase que pronunció en 1861 en la
primera sesión del parlamento dijo hemos
creado italia ahora tenemos que crear a
los italianos
lo que sucedía en italia es que habían
decidido tomar el dialecto toscano para
convertirlo en idioma oficial el
problema es que apenas el 2% de los
italianos lo hablaba
como firmaba un prestigioso historiador
a mediados del siglo 20 la idea de esta
donación vinculado a un territorio una
cultura y una historia única es la mayor
idea de los últimos 200 años decía
erigió juan tan es así que una persona
está dispuesta a matar y a morir por
ella
estas construcciones identitarias no
están exentas de prejuicios y de
equívocos es lo que los historiadores
llamamos una narrativa hegemónica una
historia que tapa otras historias
chimamanda di que es una escritora
nigeriana y ella suele decir que las
historias únicas suelen generar
estereotipos así le sucedió cuando fue a
estudiar a eeuu
en principio la sorpresa que le deparaba
a la gente que hablara bien inglés
ese es el idioma oficial de nigeria
en segundo lugar las descripciones de
áfrica como un todo homogéneo un lugar
con lindos paisajes bellos animales
donde la gente es pobre libra guerra sin
sentido y se muere decidida
luego la desazón de su profesor en su
novela porque porque los personajes se
parecían demasiado a él no eran pobres
manejaban autos y vivían en ciudades eso
no es ser africano para el profesor y
finalmente la de sus compañeros porque
por ahí salía el tema genocidio en
ruanda iglesias vos sabés no procesos de
ahí y finalmente tampoco compartían su
gusto musical dado que chimamanda le
gustaba la cantante norteamericana
mariah carey y no un grupo étnico
en nuestro caso lo que interpretamos
como identidad argentina es menos lo que
somos y más lo que queremos ser un
pueblo que bajó de los barcos europeos
sin embargo permítanme pincharles al
hilo la evidencia histórica tiene malas
noticias para ustedes
aquí barcos se refería esa frase de
octavio paz- claramente a esos barcos
del siglo 19 del siglo 20 que vinieron
con inmigrantes europeos sobre todo en
el año 1914 que es el año cuando más
inmigrantes llegaron a nuestro país sin
embargo dos siglos antes también venían
barcos o sea que hubo otras historias
otras migraciones otros barcos me estoy
refiriendo a las poblaciones africanas a
los esclavos
por tanto ese axioma de que solo venimos
de los barcos no sólo refiere a todos
los barcos sino que refiere a algunos
barcos y en algún lapso determinado
hagamos un ejercicio si todavía no se
durmieron levanten la mano a aquellas
personas en esta sala que son argentinas
si pueden ver sobre todo adelante les
cuento que todos están levantando la
mano o la mayoría de las personas
levantó la mano esto se sostiene
bastante bien y coincide con nuestra
realidad argentina en la cual apenas el
5% es extranjera es decir digamos casi
todos somos argentinas o argentinos
ahora les pido que los que son
argentinos levanten de nuevo la mano
y la bajen si tienen antepasados nacidos
en otro país
qué pasó no quedó casi ninguna mano
levantada bien esto confirmaría que
nosotros somos un país de inmigrantes
pero de ningún modo
no diría que no son argentinos en la
actualidad
dejo esto aquí por un momento voy a un
mito que dice los mapuches son chilenos
en presente son chilenos
spoiler alert falso está confirmada la
presencia mapuche en la argentina o en
lo que es hoy la argentina desde antes
de la conquista de américa entonces cuál
es la aplicación que aparentemente en
algún momento habrían venido de chile
tal vez hace 20 generaciones por tanto
hoy son argentinos si retomamos el
ejercicio que les acabo de pedir que
hagan tendríamos que concluir es que
ustedes entonces no son argentinos
porque todos tienen antepasados
extranjeros incluso podríamos concluir
que si lo que marcan la nacionalidad en
el presente son nuestros antepasados la
nacionalidad argentina no existe
entonces hasta aquí quienes somos los
argentinos bueno estamos hablando de una
identidad esquiva ambigua que se
autopercibe de una sola forma
somos en términos de otro prestigioso
historiador una comunidad imaginada que
se considera un crisol de razas
finamente seleccionadas
una comunidad imaginada que ha inventado
sus tradiciones cuidado no se ofendan no
quiero decir que nuestras tradiciones
son todas falsas y que no hay migrantes
porque ustedes lo demostraron pero que
ha impuesto algunas tradiciones por
sobre otras en el afán de ser más europa
y américa
un ejemplo bariloche san carlos de
bariloche río negro república argentina
paraíso de egresados de la secundaria
punto turístico patagónica se
autodenomina la suiza argentina
contingentes de pioneros que
construyeron a esta sus argentinas
si miramos nuevamente en 1914 el tercer
censo de la república argentina
podemos confirmar esta afirmación el 40
por ciento de los extranjeros de aquel
entonces perdón el 40 por ciento de los
barilochenses era extranjera
vamos el problema para la suiza
argentina es que el 84 por ciento de
esos extranjeros venía de chile no de
europa incluso para mala suerte para la
colonia suiza los que fundaron colonia
suiza eran pisos pero vinieron también
de chile
en este punto usted es como yo que tengo
la mayoría de mis antepasados al menos
los que conozco provenientes de los
barcos europeos podrían pensar que estas
son cosas de otras personas otras zonas
o realidades sin embargo mi opinión es
que la construcción de prejuicios pueden
resultar peligrosas en mi propia
experiencia me he topado con algunas
ideas por ejemplo en la argentina no hay
negros porque uno los mandaron al frente
de batalla y murieron todos si todos o
murieron todos en la epidemia de fiebre
amarilla de la década de 1870 repito si
todos
pero lo más llamativo es la conclusión
como en la argentina no hay negros
entonces no hay racismo
ya les mencioné el desprecio por el
pueblo mapuche y no voy a insistir
porque además carga con varias otras
acusaciones falaces pero la sorpresa que
le depara a la gente cuando digo que en
la argentina hay indígenas y en la
actualidad hay indios acá vivos me
preguntaría a susana giménez ni hablar
en la provincia de buenos aires- que les
cuento entre nosotros para molestarlos
un poco más que es la provincia con
mayor cantidad de población originaria
de nuestro país la virulencia que genera
en medios y en ciertos sectores cuando
los indígenas se organizan y reclaman
por sus derechos ahí se nos escapan de
nuestras caracterizaciones
estereotipadas se mueven nuestras
sospechas y no coinciden con las miradas
museológicas que tenemos de ellos
decimos no son indios puros
y días rara de pureza no les pregunto
para que se lleven ahora cuando se
vuelven a sus casas que será un
argentino puro por ejemplo
nuestro ejercicio 1810 eventos fundantes
de la republica argentina si
comparáramos alguna imagen con alguna
foto actual veríamos que ya no nos
vestimos igual que ya no bailamos minué
y que ya no asistimos a tertulias usted
se imaginan si por eso dijeran que
entonces como no hacemos todo eso ya no
somos argentinos o que ya no somos
argentinos puros o que ya no somos
argentinos sino que somos descendientes
de esos argentinos bueno esa falacia que
nos parece obvia no se aplica con los
pueblos indígenas cuando los vemos con
jeans o usando celular o perteneciendo a
algún grupo urbano se despiertan no esas
nuestras sospechas son indios truchos
ahí vemos como la simplificación y la
generalización son partes esenciales de
los estereotipos que creamos sobre
grupos que consideramos otros
pensemos en nuestro deporte más popular
el fútbol
hace poco volver a la cancha después de
cinco años fue en el marco de un
homenaje el organizamos a francisco
madariaga en independiente francisco es
un nieto restituido recuperar su
identidad apropiada durante la última
dictadura militar antes del partido en
pleno homenaje los aplausos bajaron y
subieron desde todas las tribunas sin
embargo terminó el homenaje empezó el
partido y los insultos me resultan
realmente chocantes y esos que debo
confesar que yo soy muy mal hablado así
lo que sucedió fue que contra el equipo
más popular de la argentina lo podemos
discutir mientras en avellaneda se
cantaba que todo era carnaval les pido
disculpas por estas palabras se cantaba
cantemos todos que la boca está de luto
que son todos negros de bolivia y
paraguay disculpas nuevamente
allí esa frase condensa todo lo que les
venía diciendo en la argentina no hay
racismo pero negro se usa como insulto
en este caso relacionado a los pueblos
latinoamericanos en especial los
migrantes y a perú el racismo deriva en
discriminación cultural hacia sectores
populares tal vez alguna vez hayan
escuchado la idea de cabecitas negras
que sacudió a mitad de siglo o el ya no
tan moderno negro cabeza
entonces se establece una relación
negativa entre lo afro que supuestamente
no existe pero sí entre lo negro que es
latinoamericano y una famosa frase que
muchos me han dicho que es ojo yo no es
que sea racista yo no digo negro de piel
digo negro de alma
tal vez piensen que exagero les propongo
una nueva versión del cántico
dice así cantemos todo ella negra está
de fiesta
cantemos todo avellaneda es carnaval
cantemos todo que la boca está de luto
que son todos blancos machos de holanda
y canadá
impensado no un cántico así bueno
en las escuelas escuché muchísimas veces
cállate boliviano nunca escuché casa
cállate sueco cállate danés
incluso formas más sutiles una colega
del mundo me contaba que en la escuela
el puesto de damas antiguos para el acto
se llenaba el de los varones vestidos
con galera y levita también pero nadie
quería ser afro o pueblo indígena
tuve una patagonia hace un tiempo
charlando con algunos profesores de
mucha experiencia oriundos de aquí pero
que emigraron a la patagonia en los 80
los 90 me contaban la paradoja de los
apellidos sus hijos se llaman nahuel
while en típicos nombres mapuche pero en
aulas con claramente predominio de
alumnos mapuches los padres habían
elegido nombres como cecilia paula pablo
kevin o jonathan
ahí podemos ver como la discriminación
va pasando de generación en generación
al punto tal de que la opción más viable
sea el auto de marcación identitaria
las abuelas más cuchi me contaban que
decían todos calladitos no digan nada
que son indígenas así le decían sus
propias abuelas a la hora de
incorporarse a la escuela
fue ayer nomás en los actos de fundación
de muchos pueblos cuando la conquista
del desierto se celebraba como una gesta
una fiesta de la patria en contra de
quienes del problema del indio aquellos
actores sociales salvajes y bárbaros que
eran parte del pasado pese a que los
estaban matando en ese mismo instante
yo creo que hay excepciones a todo esto
que le estoy contando y creo que la
herramienta es una herramienta no la
historia es una herramienta clave para
abordar todo esto esa forma tan falaz de
explicar historia de hacerle la fiestita
a la patria yo creo que lo que
deberíamos hacer es dejar de lado
nuestros prejuicios y abordar nuestros
procesos históricos sin dejar de hacer
esta cuestión que es como decía la
fiestita la patria
la historia tenía como origen o como
objetivo en su origen que tenía como
origen como objetivo crear argentinitos
y argentinita que crearan sentido de
pertenencia a nuestra patria
y seguro no conozcan a ernesto quesada
fue un multifacético historiador
y les pido que escuchen que decía al
respecto que tenía que hacer la escuela
es decir lo importante no era el
conocimiento del pasado ni tampoco la
ejercitación de un criterio propio sino
conmover los sentimientos del alumno
suscitar la adhesión a un pasado heroico
adornado por mitos y leyendas o sea no
aprender historia básicamente así fuimos
transmitiendo leyendas de generación en
generación como si fueran reales y así
se fueron cristalizando muchos sentidos
comunes por ejemplo qué pasó con
argentina porque nos llegó a hacer lo
que debió ser ese destino de grandeza
que realmente le separaba sin embargo
porque no fuimos así porque nos fuimos
nuevamente como canadá o australia
hablemos de australia por ahí estemos a
tiempo
en el año 2008 australia decidió que
tenía que hacer algo con los crímenes
que había cometido
hasta mediados de 1970 existía una ley
que le permitía el estado y la ejecutaba
secuestrar a los niños de las familias
indígenas para entregarla a la
civilización reiteró hasta 1970 se
entregaban a la civilización quienes
quienes la civilización las órdenes
religiosas y las familias blancas
en el año 2008 el primer ministro kevin
rudd decidió pedirle perdón a esos niños
que son la generación robada una
política de masas muy parecida a lo que
pasó en la argentina en la conquista del
desierto nada más que en nuestro caso
duró mucho menos pero también incluyó a
los adultos y a los ancianos
kevin rudd se dirigió a su público a los
australianos y les dijo cito por el
dolor el sufrimiento y el daño estas
generaciones robadas y a sus
descendientes por romper familias y
comunidades pedimos perdón hoy damos
este primer paso a través de reconocer
el pasado y de reclamar un futuro que
incluya a todos los australianos
un gesto simbólico pero si australia su
modelo a seguir
podríamos seguir ese tipo de ejemplos yo
creo que deberíamos reconocer de una
buena vez por todas nuestra diversidad
reflexionar en los procesos de cómo se
construyó nuestra identidad y en las
políticas materiales y simbólicas que
hoy se convierten en actos
discriminatorios y en prejuicios
piensen que recién en el siglo 21 en el
censo del 2001 por primera vez la
argentina se preguntó por su identidad
indígena y recién en el censo de 2010
por su identidad afro y también piensen
que esto fue exclusivamente obra de las
propias comunidades que reclamaron al
estado que se incluyeran esas
formulaciones
creo que se vienen tiempos desde hace
muchos años ya más respetuosos de la
diversidad cultural tal vez esto nos
ayude a tener mayores certezas sobre
nuestra identidad nacional y responder
quiénes somos esa pregunta que siempre
nos ha interpelado y como firma o como
afirmaba el escritor juan josé saer o
tal vez lo que nos define es más la
indefinición la incertidumbre y una
respuesta
la pregunta antes de la respuesta
interesante y tal vez en lugar de querer
ser algo a toda costa silenciando y
negando lo existente apelando al pasado
y a nuestra historia podamos construir
un futuro y un presente mucho más
promisorio y comprendamos de una buena
vez que lo que nos une es el respeto y
que la diversidad y las diferencias nos
enriquecen muchas gracias
[Aplausos]